bueno una intervención muy en la línea
de lo que hemos visto de gabriel boliche
en la que manifestó que el pueblo de
chile ha hablado de forma clara ha
demostrado que confía en la democracia
de hecho 13 millones de personas votaron
en el día de hoy de los 15 que estaban
convocados una participación muy alta
que no se había visto en el país el
presidente también ha señalado que va a
seguir trabajando por el tema
constitucional que es para él algo
inclaudicable y también ha hecho mención
a que va a realizar ajustes en su
gabinete también ha señalado
que
qué
que continuará el camino para sacar
adelante un proceso constitucional y se
ha referido a los problemas relacionados
con la ciudadanía afirmando que no sólo
está la preocupación de la constitución
sino también todos los problemas
vinculados con la inflación con la
seguridad con otros temas que están muy
en el corazón de los chilenos ampliando
su discurso de una forma más política y
centrándolo no solo en la constitución
haciendo haciéndose eco de ver muchas de
las preocupaciones ciudadanas claro
contános patricia cuál es ahora el clima
imaginado a nivel social e festejos de
partidario del rechazo
pues así es en las calles se celebra el
rechazo en todas las ciudades del país
bailando cueca con una gran profusión de
banderas chilenas aquellos que han
luchado por el rechazo casi desde el
proceso desde el inicio de este proceso
constituyente que fueron partidarios del
rechazo desde el plebiscito de 2020 han
salido a las calles a celebrar también
hay ciudadanos que votaron rechazo pero
opinan que no es una cuestión para
celebrar que hubieran preferido poder
optar por un texto que los hubiera
representado y finalmente también hay
manifestaciones violentas en plaza
italia por un grupo de personas aisladas
pero que sí generan represión en este
momento por parte de la policía se
escuchan sirenas en las calles de
santiago y hay gases lacrimógenos en el
centro así que un ambiente bastante
mezclado desde aquellos que celebran
hasta aquellos que también han salido a
las calles para mostrar la rabia por
estos resultados que no dejan de ser una
muestra contundente de la democracia y
de su funcionamiento